It belonged to my teacher, Master Yoda.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This will be my Mandalorian video
All about Grogu wielding a lightsaber.
people are wondering
why didn't Luke Skywalker give him Yoda's
lightsaber when he left his academy?
There's a couple of reasons
why they did it that way, and one of them
is because of what happened
with Ahsoka in her back story,
what happened with her lightsabers.
If you're brand new to the channel, I'm
doing videos
for all the Mandalorian episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them all.
But recently,
Jon Favreau revealed more about
what was happening at Luke Skywalker's
Jedi Academy with Grogu
training in the force. If it wasn't clear.
Grogan was meant to have been training
with Luke
for almost a year, like way longer
than people assumed he was.
When we were all watching those episodes.
You jump from The Mandalorian Season
two Episode eight to Book of Boba Fett.
You see him training there with Luke.
Within a few episodes,
he's back with Mando.
It seemed like it happened overnight, like
he was only there for a couple of weeks.
At the beginning of The Mandalorian Season
three, Jon Favreau
clarified that the time period of him
having been away from
Mando was meant to be closer to a year,
like he was meant to have been separate
from Mando for a long time.
And even though we've only seen him
use his force powers a little so far
this season, they also clarified
the Grogu has gotten way more powerful
than we saw
at the end of the book of Boba Fett.
So since he left Luke Skywalker's Academy,
in addition to what he learned with Luke,
he's gotten way more powerful.
So we'll continue to see him
use of force in more powerful ways
during season three.
In fact,
the next episode is called The Foundling.
We're probably going
to get more flashbacks to Order 66
and find out who end up saving him
from the Jedi Academy.
From Order 66.
And again, Skywalker
probably one of the best examples of Grogu
getting more powerful
since Book of Boba Fett is the whole idea
that during those episodes we saw him
tamed the rain cord through the force.
We just saw the myth
this or this massive beat.
It's way, way bigger,
way more hardcore than rain, cause
we all think they're eventually going
to ride the myth this or at some point.
That's the whole idea
behind the Mandalorians culture.
Based on the original Mandalore
he rode a myth or he tamed a myth or
but now it's probably going to be grogu
you to speak to the myth
A saw through the force
and get it to help them in.
According to Jon Favreau,
the series have all been moving closer
to real time one right after the other
since the beginning of season one.
So season one was meant to start
five years after Return of the Jedi.
So right now, in present day, we're almost
nine years after Return of the Jedi.
And when Luke Skywalker asks Roku
to make the choice
whether to continue training
as a Jedi at his new academy,
which they confirmed
is on the planet Arceus,
which is a huge cut from the legends canon
that used to be the original Homeworld
of the Jedi Academy.
The original Jedi Academy,
before they moved it to Coruscant.
And when Luke Skywalker
asked him to choose staying at his Jedi
Academy or going back with Mando,
choosing Yoda's lightsaber
or the Chainmail Mandalorian Beskar armor
that was meant to be a direct
reference to a samurai film
Shogun Assassin, which is a great film.
I would recommend watching it.
If you're a big fan of Samurai films,
a lot of Star Wars is inspired by
Samurai films,
but during that movie, which is based on
Lone Wolf and Cub, which heavily inspires
the tone of The Mandalorian series,
Lone Wolf and the young cub Grogu, who
the boy is presented
with a similar choice.
You must choose the ball of the sword,
even though in that example,
choosing the sword
meant choosing a life with the assassin.
Joining him on a mission to assassinate
the Shogun in a quest for revenge.
Choose the sword and you will join me.
Choose the ball
and you
join your mother
like he would choose the path of revenge.
Or if he chose the ball,
that meant joining his mother in death,
meaning he would be killed.
And when you're seeing Grogu
choose version of that choice
with Luke Skywalker,
normally you'd think the lightsaber
would represent the sword,
the laser sword,
meaning the path of revenge,
the path of the mandalorians.
But because in the Star Wars
version of that, you have the best armor
as the other choice that was meant
to represent the life with Mando,
without completely telegraphing
what Mando's eventual fate would be like,
They didn't want to get too far
ahead of the story at that point.
Grogu Who chooses a life with Mando?
But the funny thing here
is that Mando's whole arc
the setting up with the Darksaber
is essentially a similar quest for revenge
against the Empire, mostly in the form
of Moff Gideon and Grand Admiral Thrawn,
who are the remaining representatives
of the Empire who destroy the Mandalorians
Homeworld Mandalore.
Now they're on the process
of trying to reclaim it, reclaim
their people's identity, and redefine
what it means to be a mandalorian.
Like the whole title of the series
The Mandalorian is meant to refer
to many different things,
many different ideas and concepts,
but also to many different characters.
The whole series is basically
about what it means to be a mandalorian,
but right now
there's a lot of different factions.
The Mandalorians all fighting with
each other over what that actually means.
What customs do they follow,
What path does their culture take?
We're seeing that conflict
play out over the course of season
three with Mando, the Darksaber bo-katan
the armor like
even though Bo-Katan is aligned herself
with Mando in the Armors faction,
she also has a lot of different ideas
about which direction
their culture should take.
So Grogu who essentially, in choosing
the best armor the way the Mandalorian
seems like he chose the more stabby path
that he could have taken.
So given that after the fact,
a lot of people were wondering why
Luke Skywalker just didn't let Grogu
have Yoda's lightsaber when he left.
It wasn't because he was salty about Grogu
not wanting to train his Jedi academy
like, Fine, you can't have the lightsaber
anyway, I'll keep it with me.
Grogu choosing to leave his academy didn't
bother Luke at this point
in the timeline,
Luke is super zen about that,
even though he's still busy
trying to find as many force sensitive
people around the galaxy to train Grogu
who would have been his first official
pupil at the New Jedi Academy on OS's.
As far as we know,
there are no other members of Yoda species
who Luke winds up training,
so it wasn't like
there were any other members of Yoda's
species to show up and claim
Yoda's lightsaber.
Why then not let grogu
you have the lightsaber if it's just going
to be sitting in a box in Luke Skywalker
Jedi Academy for the rest of time
because we're getting ready
to get more Grogu Back Story Order
66 Back of the Jedi Academy
during the prequels
just to explain his relationship
with Yoda in Seattle.
Yoda himself would have known Grogu
who I don't think that Grogu
who is secretly a clone of Yoda,
even though there are theories
about that now because of what happened
earlier in the series.
All this talk about grogu cloning,
I think that's all a separate plot.
I think they are trying to clone
grogu you, but I think that he himself is
just meant to be a normal member of Yoda's
species, not another clone of Yoda.
We clearly saw Grogu at the Jedi Academy.
Yoda wasn't super crazy when he learned
about the original Clone Army.
He would have also
not allowed anyone to clone him too.
He would have considered
that an abomination.
Like how dare you try to clone me
in the real world?
Just in addition to that, George
Lucas has always been super protective
of the way that Star Wars treats the Yoda
character, his species in general,
especially Grogu, who now in present day
trying to prevent a lot of new law
and stories
that overexplain Yoda's back story
or explain too much about their race.
People have tried to do that
in the past, like
especially when legends can still reign
supreme before Disney.
But Star Wars
people would come along
trying to explain more about Yoda's
backstory, tell more stories
about Yoda's history, and usually Lucas
would put the kibosh on that
as he would allow a lot of other stuff
to fly just to keep Yoda as mysterious
a character as possible.
We do know his race is meant
to be extremely rare in the galaxy.
They're all born incredibly powerful
in the force,
in their natural environment,
or typically swampy areas like Dagobah.
Yoda would have known where
members of his race were in the galaxy.
But it's not information.
He would have been broadcasting
24 seven for hundreds of years
for everyone in the Republic to see like,
Hey, everybody, come look at the members
of my species hidden all over the galaxy.
He would have also been the person to find
Grogu and bring him to the Jedi Academy
when Grogu was much younger
and begin his training,
even if Yoda himself wasn't Grogu's
only Jedi master.
When people are brought
to the Jedi Academy,
most kids are around the age of four,
and a lot of initial
basic training that they do
are under many different Jedi masters,
like very Rudimentary Day
one type of training.
So it wasn't like Rogue
who only trained under Yoda.
I also don't think that Grogu was Yoda
or Seattle's child,
even though there were all those
Maury memes during season one.
Like hit it, Yoda did it and quit it.
But if there were so few members
of their race, Grogu
would literally have been
one of the only beings
capable of using Yoda's lightsaber
after his death.
So Yoda would have wanted grogu
you to have it eventually.
And if it wasn't clear
just the way the force goes
work, Yoda can show up to appear
to anyone that he wants to.
It doesn't have to be another Jedi.
So even after his death,
in Return of the Jedi, Yoda could still be
looking over Grogu and have visited him
at some point.
Here's where we get to Ahsoka
when we talk about why Grogu
didn't take Yoda's
lightsaber with him when he left Luke.
What happened with Grogu,
who is meant to be very similar
to what happened with Ahsoka
when she left the Jedi Order.
When she left the Jedi Order,
she left her lightsabers with them.
So she didn't have lightsabers
for a little while.
A little later in the Clone Wars
timeline and again, Skywalker gave her her
lightsabers back repaired and polished
as he says, good as new
and took care of the goods.
Now, even though right after this
she lost, wandering the chaos of Revenge
of the Sith in order 66
and left the second one behind
in order to fake her death
so that the Empire
would think that she was dead.
She didn't know the Anakin Skywalker
had just become Darth Vader
officially till a little bit later.
She wasn't thinking about hiding from.
And again, when she did this,
she was just trying to hide
from the Emperor's forces in general.
Little more time goes
by. She's hiding in the outer rim.
We saw that during Tales of the Jedi.
She doesn't have her own lightsaber yet,
but she eventually encounters
a sixth inquisitor and winds up
purifying his lightsaber crystals,
using them to build her twin white
lightsabers that you see her now using in
present day during The Mandalorian.
So part of the idea and having Grogu
leave without Yoda's lightsaber
is that he's seeking his own
path to the force like Ahsoka did.
Like he won't become a Jedi,
just like Ahsoka did not become a Jedi.
They're both turning into something
completely different.
And also like Ahsoka Grogu, who will
eventually craft his own lightsaber.
In addition to that, though,
because there's been a lot of theories
about this, people wondering,
will he wield the darksaber?
Because it will be awesome to see Grogu
using the Darksaber in some way.
In so much of the Mandalorian series plot
revolves around the Darksaber
It is another lightsaber.
It's just a different kind of lightsaber.
So yes, I totally think that Grogu
will eventually use the darksaber
but with a twist.
If you think about it
this way, practically the hilt is way
too big for him
to wrap his tiny little fingers around.
So I think it's more likely
that he would use the force to wield it.
Like he'll swing it around,
but he'll be pushing it
around with the force
which Jedi used to do all the time.
Force throw their light sabers
if he were going to actually wield
the lightsaber
like a traditional fighting stance
where he swings around with his hands
the hilt would have to be Yoda size.
And also right now, like in present day,
he's still a fraction
of Yoda's size,
so his hands are even smaller than Yoda's.
If he used both of them,
he could probably wrap them
around Yoda's hilt,
but even that would be a bit of a stretch
at this point.
Like the lightsaber
itself would still be way bigger than him.
It would make more sense for him
to wield a light saber
by pushing it around in the force.
For those wondering
about how fast Yoda's species grows,
Yoda became a Jedi master
when he was about 90 years old.
Grogu, who is currently in his mid-fifties
and think about how big he is.
So he'll pie grow pretty quickly over
the next 30 years to physical maturity.
But that's a long time.
Like 30 years
isn't exactly the blink of an eye,
but that's about how long it would take
for his hands to physically get as large
as Yoda.
His hands in long term is cool
as it would be sick rogue
who take the darksaber and for it
to become his permanent lightsaber.
I don't think that's going to happen.
I think ultimately the Darksaber
will wind up staying in the hands
of a human Mandalorian in just
passed through their line in Grogu
will just wind up building his own
completely different lightsaber one
with a tiny little Yoda sized hilt.
Even after he grew to Yoda size,
his hands would still be too tiny
to wrap around the hilt of the Darksaber
let me know in the comments though.
Grogu, who eventually winds up
building his own lightsaber.
What color do you want it to be?
A big reminder to my Mandalorian Season
three Episode four Video We'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here to watch that video,
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here
for all my other Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.